衛星熊れって言うと間もなくジジイババアと言われます
こんにちははじめ社長ですというわけですね訂正最初の動画でございます米はに入って
初めて撮る動画です皆さん例は自体も肇社長をよろしくお願い致しますと言いたい
ところではあるんですけども平成もですねあの皆さんに本当大変お世話になりました
平成もありがとうございましたありがとうございました
レイバー一発目何をしたいかと言いますどうぞまでまでこの平成の鬼没が抜け切れて
ないというか
ここ平成のねなんかこう
平成
平成がも大勢オッケカムカモン
体制
フェア異性がまだ抜け切れてないというところがありまして何かの僕最近ですね愚民に
食ってるだけの動画が1億回戦していったりして結構あん
平成の youtube 会にあの自分で言うのはなんですけども結構歴史を残すてる
と思ってるんでしょ自分で何で多分グミーくるだけで1億開催していく人あの
ユーチューバーでそういないと思うんで自分でつずつ上恥ずかしいね
けどもまぁ平成が生んだって歳かもしれないであるとかありまして僕が平成位のときに
作った youtube の動画をちょっと見返してみようかなと思いまして
まあ良くも悪くもですよ編者の仕方とかいろいろ変わってきてて本柱の動画が今の僕に
どう売ってるかどうしてそんなに再生回数が入ったかとかがわかったりそれがも住んで
シア懐かしいなぁって平成
を振り返りにもなると思うのでちょっと平成の歴史的な僕の動画を僕も一緒に見て
いこうと思いますというわけで今日の動画
管理者庁の平成の動画を一緒に観返していこうのコーナーです数は少なくなりますが
肇社長が底した平成の名作動画
一緒に見ていきましょうベアどうぞ入ってるでしょミディ
みましょう最初の動画ですね世界最大級の組を一人で食うという動画ですもうタイトル
の通りなんですけどこれが僕のチャンネルでへぇ
西1番再生されて動画ですもうの1億開催するこういうてて本当にすごいんですよ
なんですごいか分からないですけどねまあそういうのが何か分かればいいなと思って
改めて私が残した平成の名作見ていきましょう
ではお願いします
元気ですね技
俗に言う回数が技というやつですね
いいいいいいいい
はぁっはぁっはぁっ
ありません
元気ですね元気元気山峡ねー
でも26になって開封の儀装と疲れるから願ってます
右腕世界
袋から開けます
[音楽]
のに黒いん
ちゃいいさ
日焼けしてね日やけを押すてるし直接机に組を叩きつけるんだねー
バカな子だよ
[音楽]
アン脱ぎレッドなカーブしてみたいな方
酔った髪はたよこれ本当味な対外さん
なんですけども
東場所保存しようニコアプリだこっちはねーぞ
まだ
なんで開け鑑賞から1個の人気を滞在級の祖母含み
はいおりでく今
4000キロ緒莉ぐらいか何かそういう話もあっ
でも俺絶対食えないんだよなぁ
筆記受けに行ってみたと思ってたんでしょうねそうですからー
この兄弟常に長らくいます
いただけます
重い勢いしかないかん
また4910億円からねぇ
じゃあこれ混ぜ機買ったんでしょと多いかなちょっとこいつぁないです
あまえん
なんか
エロいねこれ公庫からなんか色々には始まってるとが住んだよなぁ
すごいなんてな巨大な蛇食ってるだけだけど自分で生まれですけど面白いですねー
[音楽]
本日け
ん設計気持ちより買った覚えがありますねぇ
やばいは思ってると思う
僕はん
いいと思ったんですけど海だこれじゃないよ
組だわ思ってるとそっちは頑張るん
無理してんな俺当時から映像に
てるハイウェイです
う
赤くなってるん
[音楽]
はいはいだろうからならの編集の仕方が変わったなぁってめっちゃもうねぇ
全然テキストもなかったけどジェット右田なっつーことはテキストいらないっていう
ことを
動画のテキストトイレからとかちょっとわかんないです今なんか程よく入れてるんです
けど
あと乙もなんか時ようでしたねまたまた若いころです次の動画なんですけども
コーナー黒にから図面と数で入ってみた
なるほど見てみますか
これで逆にねなんでエンゾしなかったんだろうと思ってるとかあるんですよね
なんか正直ニベア黒いるタチ悪いなと思っててないも
のみ飲み物で音を作るんですよ途中まで来るでしょ
お金もつですね金を目指す会と末に住んぬ
その後トレチワワってよかなんだねあなこの頃からなんかいっ
えっ
塩蔵金利してたんですよねつぎ行きません明太子が72個置いてるんですけど
カーンはなんとですねほら120リットルを使ってお風呂にコーラぶろぐっ
そこにあっならテキストが小さい増資とか竈大減税一見炮烙櫓に備えています
もったいないって
馬鹿野郎
男なザ男
イズっているのですねっ
ないようぜあっはっ行ったり映画男だったからですかね
うわぁ
暇やなーします今多分できるんだよね時間がなくてそのこの頃はね淳一中動画に時間を
かけるだからねぇ
めっちゃ時間かけてどうぞとコメしたんだねっでも体に待っとるとき
入っに時間を取っていたらもっといいねんっ当面ロス4校減っ
セロハンテープ oa 何度しかねーっ
あそここれを体に入っ
これ数を103位と4理解
この感じで寝風呂に飛び込むと思う
色々といろいろテーマにも
んだこれ hey じゃきまーす
ああああああ
[音楽]
どえいえーい
too
バッハ
終わり方雑やなぁてぼっちが見つかんなかったんでしょうね
当然そんな中何かやりあい屋みたいなところだったんで今の俺だったら許せないかも
しれないね
三重がありましたね次はちょっとユーチューバー版 ppap ペンパン屋ポテですね
ナッツ
見てみようと思います
昔も平成
つったらこれだったみたいの買ったかねぇ
dele
みるのきつ
pane
アイハバアトウ
pa
チャンパ oda なんとかって子8体だプー
rar
アポって
タイのポップ
[音楽]
ああああああ
やっぱっっ生き愛をの勢いがすごいなぁ
andere
あぽぱいあぽぺあそエアー当然
後不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不
ポパイああああやっぱ
枚4
前編で発泡 pen at ぺたいなぁそう先輩の目の前なボーイだった
あって名前はきもいきもいきもよ
バッハ
ゆかっていた
[音楽]
バッハ
遊んでこいなさせ800円ファイなせてあっとって動い
u 2本テーマ3月が綺麗だったらフィッかっけー
そう
car
パイナップアップをペン
me
最弱とあっぽっぺんは当然
car
by naco アップステップああああっ
イカツいアジアじゃこれなぜコメしようと思ったんだろうなぁ
ああああああん
木崎位
入ってゆけでいかがだったでしょうかも
何だろうね最後のやつは面白かったってかもうなんか見て出来もつあると思ったんです
けどあのなんか特に
平成が居るからって何が変わるわけじゃないんですけども時代が変わる節目を見られた
ということで
例はもう引き続き
始めるぞ頑張るつ折れないですけど僕が楽しいと思える動画そしてそれを何か見て
もらってまっつまらないと思われてもいいし面白かったら面白いと言ってくれてもいい
し
まあみんなで楽しめればいいなと思っております開けない
ウェーバーも始めたぞよろしくお願い muscle
こういうのがダメなんだよな
me
[音楽]